Hi, I am Phil Sali, and we're going to be looking at, uh,
community Group Leader Certification. Tonight we'll be looking at the, uh,
role of the Bible teacher,
and we know that Bible teachers are gifted and called of God to instruct
believers and provide spiritual nourishment for, uh, God's people.
And so we're going to look at three essential truths.
The value and responsibility of the Bible teacher is described in scripture
number two,
the indispensable role of the community group leadership or discussion guide.
And finally, the Bible teacher as disciple maker.
So let's look at the value and the responsibility of the Bible teacher as
described in scripture. Without question,
the Bible teacher plays a key role in the community group,
and they're key because they're called to equip the disciples of Jesus Christ.
Bible teachers shape spiritual growth and spread the gospel of Jesus Christ.
Bible teachers are aware that they're gonna be held to a higher degree of
accountability.
James one gives a warning to teachers and tells them that they will be judged
with a greater strictness. In fact, it says,
not many of you should become teachers, my brothers. So consequently,
we take very seriously the responsibility of guiding others.
We know that there are, if there are any errors or mis misrepresentations,
they can even, uh, even if they're not intentional,
they can significantly impact the spiritual development of the learners.
So our role as Bible educators and influencers demands greater scrutiny.
So let's look at the scripture passages and as it pertains to our value and our
responsibility. As Bible teachers,
Bible teachers understand the indeni undeniable power of God's word.
Hebrews four 12 describes the word as living and active and uses the
metaphor sharper than a two-edged sword.
That means that it can penetrate souls and discern thoughts and convict
hearts. The Bible teachers faithful ex of Jesus,
that's exposition and application of the scriptures,
can assist God to bring about genuine transformation in the lives of believers.
Number two, Bible teachers embrace the authority and sufficiency of scripture.
Bible teachers know that in two Timothy three 16 and 17,
that the scripture comes from divine origin. In fact,
God breathed given the very life breath of God. And so,
but they hold the authority of the Bible's infallible revelation, the, uh,
ability to confront corruption and guide believers in righteousness and equip
them for every good work.
Bible teachers help believers grasp the power and perfection of scripture.
Number three, Bible teachers discern the undeniable effectiveness of the gospel.
Romans one 16 and 17 declares the gospel's power to save all who
believe the Bible teachers are instrumental in faithfully presenting the gospel
of Jesus. Paul said, I'm not ashamed of the gospel of Christ.
It's the power of God for salvation, for everyone who believes.
But listen to verse 17, for in it the gospel of Jesus Christ,
a righteousness from God is revealed.
So we're not teaching or equipping saints to be righteous for themselves through
the gospel, we're connecting them to the power of God. Number four,
the Bible teachers recognize how faith comes through hearing the word of Christ.
In Romans 10 17,
we hear about the importance of hearing the word of Christ to cultivate faith.
So we as Bible teachers, serve as conduits for this hearing,
enabling believers to develop and strengthen their faith through the study and
proclamation of the scriptures. Now, number five,
Bible teachers understand the word of God as a spiritual shield and protector.
Psalms 1 19, 9 through 11 emphasizes the role of God's word in guarding against
sin.
And so the Bible teachers model for the believers in their class how to hide
God's word in their hearts,
empowering them to resist temptation and to walk in obedience.
Number six,
Bible teachers appreciates how the word of God shines light on the path of life.
In Psalms one 19 verse 1 0 5, it says,
your word is a lamp into my feet and a light into my path.
So our role as Bible teachers is to eradicate darkness and
educate believers in the scripture as to illuminate and enable them to
navigate life's challenges and make good decisions. Number seven,
the Bible teachers honor the Bible as the source of truth. In John 1717,
we have recorded Jesus' prayer and he declares the absolute
truthfulness of God's word and understands that that truthfulness is
our path to genuine sanctification. So through understanding biblical truth,
Bible teachers can help believers discern God's will and distinguish it from
less truthful perspectives and even outright lies from the deceiver.
Number eight,
Bible teachers take hold of the potential of scripture for producing spiritual
fruit.
One Peter 1 23 compares the word of God to a living and
imperishable seed.
So Bible teachers plant and nurture the seed in the hearts of believers,
which leads to spiritual growth and maturity.
So from a community group member's perspective,
Bible teachers hold immense value because they're equipping them with this
transformative power of God's word,
which leads to an authentic faith in Jesus Christ helps us,
helps them guard against sin and provides guidance in navigating life's
challenges. So with unwavering commitment,
Bible teachers serve as a catalyst for spiritual growth and the spread of the
gospel message.
And they lay a firm foundation for believers to live out their faith with
boldness and victory. Number two,
essential truth is the indispensable role of the community group discussion
guide. Now,
in a rapidly evolving world or devolving world where
spiritual
Values are eroding and spiritual beliefs are constantly challenged,
the role of the Bible teacher has never been more crucial.
We just read nine different scripture passages challenging us to maintain
our, uh, our devotion to teaching God's word correctly.
But Bible teachers have to learn to, uh,
assist and come alongside as gifted and called,
come alongside the Lord who has the power to shape minds and instill values and
inspire profound transformation.
So in order to do this noble task, we, uh,
encourage the use of a sound Bible teaching curriculum or, um,
different kinds of commentaries or resources that will help you in your
discovery of the meaning of the text.
And so the discipleship and community staff is committed to providing a
teaching curriculum for Bible teachers.
It's well designed and Bible teachers can use it to help them navigate
this vast and intricate, uh, gift that God has given us his holy word.
Uh,
what you'll do when you use a proven curriculum resource is that
you'll know that the Bible knowledge that you're receiving from this resource is
accurate and relevant and applicable to the lives of your community Group
members. Now,
community group discussion guide curriculum is written and edited specifically
for Henderson Hills Baptist Church Community Group teachers. What that means is,
uh, that the passage will coincide with what Pastor John is preaching,
but it's not tied to the sermon.
The curriculum is also written in and edited with our church's mission and
vision and values in mind.
So rather than using a mass produced off the shelf curriculum, our staff,
uh, is gonna provide a curriculum that's designed specifically for our community
group teachers. Consequently,
community group members discussion,
their focus is specifically formed according to the mission and vision and
values of the Henderson Hills Baptist Church.
So with the community group discussion guide, curriculum,
teachers can be confident that the curriculum has been carefully compiled and
written with what we call strict hermeneutical discipline. Well,
hermeneutics is the art and science of precise biblical interpretation.
The primary purpose of hermeneutics is to discover the clearest and plainest
truth and values expre expressed in the passage.
Hermeneutical hermeneutical discipline examines the passages,
authorship estimates the date, takes the, uh,
biblical genre into consideration, and looks at the passage that,
that we're studying for its historical context,
sometimes delves into word studies and also takes in mind the author's
readership. Why?
Because we want to know what the original language was intended to be,
uh, told.
And so the curriculum is trustworthy because the writers and the editors are
from Henderson Hills,
and they're dedicated to discovering the clearest and plainest meaning of the
passage according to the context of the original audience.
So the primary task isn't hermeneutics, it's called exegesis. Now,
exegesis is a critical explanation of the biblical text.
So the curriculum is written and compiled independent of the sermon sermon,
but through proper ex of Jesus,
we'll provide Herman Hermeneutical insights to the sermon.
So the discussion questions which come alongside the ex of Jesus will assist the
teacher in drawing connections between the biblical principles,
the contemporary challenges, and the context of the class,
which only the teacher would know. So to, uh, wrap it up,
I I'm really a big fan and big proponent of our community group discussion
guides. I want you to know that this curriculum fosters consistency.
I know several of our community groups have a multiple of teachers,
and for them to be able to use the exact same curriculum writing staff in this
exact same voice fosters consistency,
and it helps prevent subjective or false interpretations that could lead to
confusion or even worse misinterpretation of God's divine truth.
So students in our community groups deserve a cohesive and
systematic approach that enables them to comprehend and understand the Bible's
teaching in a trustworthy and sound doctrinal way. Uh,
furthermore,
the thoughtful constructed community group discussion guide empowers teachers
to address the diverse needs of their unique community group.
You know your group, and you know how this cu curriculum is gonna be used.
And this curriculum is only a tool and it's used with the, uh, with the, uh,
ability of the teacher to make it its own.
And so by using this community group discussion guide,
teachers also are modeling, modeling integrity and accountability.
So when teachers have access to this well-researched theologically sound
curriculum,
then they can confidently stand behind their teachings knowing that they're
grounded in biblical truth, not just mirror opinions.
So in conclusion, bringing us to the end of our second point,
the importance of the community group discussion guide, uh,
cannot be overstated. It serves as the foundation upon which we, uh,
help impact our class members on a spiritual journey.
It's comprehensive and reliable,
and with it Bible teachers can shape minds and inspire hearts and foster a
deeper understanding of love in God's timeless word.
Which brings me to the final point. And that's the Bible teacher.
As a disciple maker,
becoming a Bible teacher of a community group involves much more than just
teaching the Bible. A disciple maker, uh,
endures resistance and develops people and reproduces themselves so that they
can become disciples of Jesus Christ.
The importance of a Bible teacher in reproducing themselves and developing an
apprentice cannot be overstated. As a Bible teacher,
the primary responsibility is to ensure the continuity and stability
of effective Bible teaching for the future. And how do we do that? Well,
we make disciples who make disciples.
That's the mission and vision of our church.
We develop a capable apprentice in the community group,
and then we pass on our wisdom and our experience and our skills.
We encourage and we coach them. And then in doing so,
we create a seamless transition when the time comes for community group to
multiply and start a new group. So, developing an apprentice Bible teachers,
not just ensuring a, a smooth succession plan in the community group,
but also understanding how God raises up leaders to effectively navigate the
future growth of the class.
Now remember we talked about the modern landscape and how the, the, uh,
spiritual landscape seems to be eroding with all new challenges and
difficulties. Well,
Bible teachers who've been uniquely designed by God can think creatively
and teach in a manner that empowers their apprentice
Bible teacher.
And then the new Bible teacher can infuse this fresh per fresh perspective
that only God has given him with a unique viewpoint into the teacher's role.
So not only is the, uh, church's strengths, uh,
have the ability to navigate navigate complex situations,
it instills as,
as a teacher develops an apprentice who then begins to teach their own class.
The class then learns a sense of trust and loyalty among fellow members,
knowing that their Bible teacher is committed to their growth and their
launching as instruments of grace in the kingdom of God.
So ultimately,
the act of reproducing oneself as a Bible teachers transcends
any individual accomplishments and self-interests because it becomes a vital
aspect of building a resilient and forward-looking church that can thrive
in an ever-changing world. Uh,
my wife has a beautiful illustration that says, uh,
a wise teacher is one who plants acorns knowing full well they will never sit
under the shade of the oak tree to come.
So we're learning that developing a Bible teaching apprentice
fosters a culture of growth and learning within the community group,
and it motivates the community group members to recognize the value of spiritual
growth and want to invest themselves in their own spiritual development.
Um, and this is also how a Bible teacher develops a legacy not
only in their ability to teach the Bible,
but also on their ability to impact the future of future Bible teachers.
So let's, let's just be honest for a minute.
Disciple making is difficult because, uh, we have mutually loving relationships.
Bible teachers develop strong bonds of relationships between, uh,
group community group members, and, uh,
they're encouraged to grow deeper in their relationship with one another.
And then they do.
And then we ask these same community group members to leave those relationships
and start a new community group.
And it cannot happen without a Bible teacher casting the vision if the Bible
teacher doesn't cast the vision.
And if the Bible teacher doubts the effectiveness of the multiplication process,
the process then becomes confusing and leads to frustration.
But disciple making community group Bible teachers educate the people about the
disciple making process.
They take time to describe and envision and invest in this process.
They describe the whys of disciple making as well as the hows of multiplying.
Now, it would by be naive for discipleship,
making teachers to expect anyone just to jump on board the multiplication
process without explaining it or believing in them, in it with themselves.
But with time and patience and love,
the in the instruction of the community group can,
they'll begin to understand and maybe adapt to this disciple making process.
Every community group teacher must remember that the group, the community group,
class members don't belong to them, rather they belong to God.
In fact, community group members are just on loan from God,
and thus for just a short period of time,
because God has entrusted Bible teachers with responsibility of caring for their
souls and feeding them spiritually so that they can grow up and become mature
men and women of faith, and then begin to serve him using their own gifts.
God never intended a community group member to sit in a class for many,
many years, most of their lives,
and never experienced the joy and fulfillment of getting out on their own and
making disciples of Jesus. Uh, I remember having children in the home,
and I loved being a dad.
And then there was a period where they were middle schoolers,
and we began to understand these kids are growing up and they became teenagers.
And, uh, and I loved my teenagers, but it was a challenging time.
And there was a point in the life of these teenagers where I was thinking,
I think it's time for them to get out on their own.
And how sad would it be if my 30 and 40 year old, uh, children,
adult children, still lived at home with me? But no,
they're out and they're making their way in the Lord and using the, uh,
gifts that God has given them. And that's how disciples are made.
A Bible teacher's job is complete when he is equipped people to the point that
they understand the purpose of their own calling,
and then they seek a place to minister. So in conclusion,
the role of a Bible teachers carries immense value and biblical responsibility
to shape hearts and minds of people that the Bible teacher teaches.
And with the support of a trustworthy
And doctrinally sound curriculum,
that the Bible teacher holds the power to guide the community group members into
spiritual maturity and to lead them to dive deeper into the timeless wisdom
scripture for themselves. However, the ultimate goal is this. We,
as we embrace Jesus noble calling,
we usher in a transformative ripple effect that touches lives
far beyond our immediate reach.
We foster a legacy of faith and love and wisdom that endures for
generations.
And together let us learn to take up the mantle of disciple making with
dedication and passion, because in our hands,
we hold the ability and the potential to shape not just the individual,
but to help accomplish God's mission,
to reach the world with the good news of Jesus Christ.